[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAY TSANG: In this
video, you'll learn
how to quickly adopt
Google Cloud platform
services with Springboard
framework using Spring Cloud
GCP.
GCP engineers have been working
closely with the Spring teams
to produce idiomatic
integrations
for many of our GCP services.
Let's see how you can
use Cloud Spanner,
add distributed
tracing to Cloud Trace,
send logs to Cloud Logging
with a Spring Boot application.
First, create a new application
using Spring Initializer
at start.spring.io.
In the bottom, you
can add dependencies
to add capabilities to your
application at GCP support.
Generate the application and
open it in your favorite IDE.
You can use Spring Data
with Cloud Spanner,
so you can take advantage
of Spring Data features,
such as object relational
mapping, crowd repository,
inventing, and auditing.
First, add the Spring Cloud
GCP Cloud Spanner starter.
Create a POJO for object
relational mapping.
Annotate the POJO
with Cloud Spanner
annotations to configure a
table mapping and primary keys.
Rather than creating your
own data access object,
you can use Spring
Data's repository
to automatically generate and
implement cloud operations
to Cloud Spanner.
In application.properties,
configure the Cloud Spanner
instance ID and database
ID to connect to.
You can then use the repository
for basic cloud operations.
But you can also
enhance the repository
with additional finder
methods or custom queries.
Spring Data will
automatically infer the query
from the name of the
method, or use a query
that you provide, using
the query annotation.
Finally, rather than creating
your own RestController
by hand, you can also use
Spring Data REST repository
to automatically
create and expose
a RESTful service
that can perform
cloud operations against
the Cloud Spanner database.
It's important to understand
the topology of your distributed
system.
You can accomplish
this through the use
of distributive tracing.
You can use Spring
Cloud GCP Trace
Starter to add the
distributive tracing capability
to your service.
It uses Spring Cloud
Sleuth underneath,
so it's native to
Springboard applications.
And they will automatically
capture and propagate
the trace ID, the span ID.
And it will automatically
configure Spring Cloud Sleuth
to send traces to Cloud Trace
By default, Spring Cloud Sleuth
will only sample and report
10% of the requests.
You can adjust the
sampling probability.
For this demo, were
adjusted to 100%.
And this is all it takes
to add distributed tracing
to send traces to Cloud Trace.
Similarly, to send log
messages to Cloud Logging,
simply add the Spring
Cloud GCP Logging Starter.
Then configure the standard
logback configuration
to use Cloud Logging appendix.
There are two
appendix you can use.
If you're running
on premise, you
can send log entries to the API.
Or if you're running
in GKE, you can
use the JSON appender to produce
JSON format log entries that's
understood by GKE
In both cases, you do not
need to change any code.
Simply use the
existing appenders.
And most importantly, the
trace context information
will be automatically
added to the log entry,
so that later, you can
correlate the trace graph
with the corresponding
log messages.
Let's go take a look.
In the Trace console,
we can clearly
see the trace associated
with a request
but also, its subsequent course.
Check the show logs checkbox.
And the related log
messages are also displayed.
With Spring Cloud
GCP, you can quickly
create services or
migrate existing services
to utilize GCP.
You can use Spring data with
Cloud Spanner, Firestore,
and Data Store.
You can add distributed
tracing and centralize logging
without adding custom code.
And there's so much more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]